turning to a growing problem in the
world's oceans lost and abandoned
fishing gear what's known as ghost gear
litters the sea floor threatening marine
life and the livelihoods of fishermen
around the globe in maine for instance
an estimated get this 10 of all lobster
traps are lost every year which adds up
to about 280 000 traps in all for our
series i on earth nancy chen traveled to
portland maine to find out what's been
done to solve the problem
on the surface portland maine's
coastline looks like a classic new
england picture postcard
but lurking just a few feet below
another world
one of long forgotten fishing nets ropes
and lobster traps tangled together over
years by storms and currents
if you throw it over the side it never
leaves it's still there
lobsterman jim buxton has worked the
waters off portland for more than 30
years
he led us three miles off shore to
whitehead passage where we watched him
haul up today's catch a ball of lost and
abandoned fishing gear twisted with his
own that's probably six or eight traps
than the
rope for a string and
a piece of gill net that was drifting
around the bottom how did you find it it
was wrapped up in some lobster gear i
was actually actively fishing this is
gilnet
it's known as ghost gear that's a
trapdoor this is a shrimp twine head
which we started using in the late 80s
early 90s how long do you think this has
been under water
i'm estimating like 15 years plus in
2019 buxton helped recover this seven
ton ball of ghost gear off nearby cape
elizabeth but that's just a small
fraction of the more than 600 thousand
tons of fishing gear thought to be added
to the world's oceans each year it's
really something that is out of sight
out of mind for most folks jacqueline
mcgarry is the program manager for the
global ghost care initiative or triple
gi at the ocean conservancy the triple
gi is an alliance of 18 nations dozens
of companies universities and ngos ghost
gear is the most harmful form of marine
debris to wildlife
but it is also really harmful to fishers
and coastal communities who depend on
income from fishing and it is a problem
pretty much anywhere you find fishing
anywhere in the world
all over the world
ghost skier can unintentionally trap
injure or even kill marine life last
year divers freed this whale from a
tangled fishing net off the coast of
italy is the solution to all this in the
prevention or in the removal of ghost
gear it really is about both preventing
it from ending up in our ocean in the
first place
minimizing the amount of damage it does
and then recovering what's easily able
to be recovered
like the ghost gear buxton found on a
dive at the end of a fishing pier in
downtown portland
there was so much a crane had to be
brought in to lift it out of the water i
mean this is a challenge aaron paletier
runs the gulf of maine lobster
foundation and works with the triple gi
and fishermen like buxton to organize
local cleanups you know when you're
pulling it up out of the water and
you're waiting to see
what it is it's like waiting for
christmas
wow what is this
among the finds a door ladder and plenty
of traps nets and rope about two tons in
all
that hits you right in the nostrils
holy moly no one had really approached
the subject before fishermen in general
don't want their fingers pointed at them
because this is nothing they do on
purpose but they started to realize why
don't we be stewards of the environment
and help with the process rather than
pretend it's not there how important is
it to have that partnership with them
it's critical and they know where the
stuff is
they're the ones who get on the water i
don't dive so
we wouldn't be able to do it without
them a sometimes tedious task in what
can feel like just a drop in the ocean
but buxton wouldn't have it any other
way how do you feel bringing this stuff
up
good i've been a diver since 83
the average person never sees the bar
this is part of fishing you know and i
i'm a fisherman i feel responsible to
help clean it up
removing the ghost gear of years past
and keeping these waters full of life
for cbs mornings i'm ninci chen in
portland maine
it's amazing what's down there and
that's a big project i wish them the
best but while they're down there i did
lose a pair of sunglasses in the
chesapeake in the 90s if they see them
yeah can i get them back part of the 600
000 tons of stuff that's not for sherman
gear there's a lot of stuff down there
it's what we don't see yeah cars wallets
treasure
lots of it what i love about sunglasses
what i love about these pieces is it
brings to light something most people
don't think about
and then the fact that they're actually
doing something about it because a lot
of times when you think of climate and
these ion earth segments you kind of
leave feeling like what's the solution
what yeah are we going to do it's the
places we will never get our eyes on so
for them to give us that eye-opening
story absolutely it's important for us
to know these things for sure for sure i
on earth